this is the weit room this is the
wrestling room baby this is the auto
shop this is our
nitorum this is the carel varsity gym
this is our live radio this tour of a
Caramel Indiana high school is going
viral again commenters were quick to
Memon how supposedly unfair American
public school funding is even calling it
racist in reality every public high
school in nearby Indianapolis spends
more per pupil than carel despite
achieving much worse results just
because a school is bad doesn't mean
it's underfunded here's proof Utah which
has the second lowest funded schools in
the nation has similar test scores to
nearby Wyoming which spends almost
$10,000 more per student the
relationship between school funding and
school quality is extremely weak that's
because many public schools overspend on
Administration and employee benefits so
no just because of school is nice
doesn't mean it's flush with cash